vous posez la question du nombre de
films c'est évidemment pas à nous de
répondre à cette question
arde avant a expliqué que de notre point
de vue du point de vue de la gestion de
l'entreprise nous allions nous
concentrer pour faire moins de films et
il se trouve qu'effectivement la France
produite beaucoup de films mais je pense
que véritablement s'il doit une
évolution et de de la réglementation
c'est au CNC qui vous posez la question
parce que c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
le CNC qui décide si vous voulez de
comment le nombre de films mais quand
même lié au système de l'avant sur
recette des subventions et c'est
subventions sont peut-être pourraient
être donné d'une manière différente mais
c'est pas à nous oui c'est pas à nous de
de répondre à cette question
il est il est toujours certain que si on
fait trop de choses à un avantage c'est
qu'on ouvre si vous voulez des
possibilités peut-être à des gens qui ne
ferait pas de film
mais en l'ouvrant on a tendance à un peu
à saupoudrer et à son poudrer on est
éventuellement moins efficace donc si on
veut être plus efficace il faut
peut-être avoir des règles un peu plus
strictes sur la sélection des gens qui
reçoivent des subventions mais c'est pas
à nous oui c'est pas à nous de répondre
à cette question c'est je pense d'une
partie peut-être à vous peut-être au CNC
puis peut-être au public mais je pense
très réellement qu'il y ait une
évolution pour aller aussi que les gens
qui vont au cinéma qui est une évolution
qui aux États-Unis depuis très longtemps
c'est que qui existait avant le covid
c'est que aller au cinéma par rapport à
rester chez soi à regarder télévision
c'est un certain effort et vous avez
cité une phrase je me reciterai pas
moi-même parce que je vais trouver que
j'avais peut-être été un peu vulgaire ce
jour-là mais
voilà donc
je pense que aller au cinéma qu'il
demande un certain effort on y va pour
son plaisir voilà même si quel que soit
le film on va voir alors ça peut être on
peut chercher à avoir un film de grand
spectacle la France a une grande
réputation dans le film d'auteur et il y
a des gens qui ont envie de voir des
films d'auteur mais le film d'auteur
ou s'il faut qu'il atteigne un certain
niveau que les gens c'est les gens qui
décident oui si un film marche c'est pas
c'est pas CNC c'est pas vous c'est pas
nous c'est le spectateur qui qui qui
finalement décide et le spectateur ça
lui arrive de se tromper mais il se
trompe pas tellement
et quand un film ne marche pas c'est
rarement un film excellent bon ça peut
arriver mais c'est très rare voilà donc
la France est un pays qui a défendu
depuis toujours la diversité du cinéma
c'est une de ses forces donc le le même
si moi je peux trouver quelques fois il
y a trop de films néanmoins je défendrai
la diversité c'est très important mais
diversité peut-être pas
peut-être peut-être mais c'est il faut
voir ça que le CNC c'est le CNC qui a si
vous voulez qui décrète les aides
peut-être que c'est trop facile c'est
peut-être quelquefois trop facile de
faire un mauvais film